this is al jazeera hello i'm adrian
finnegan in doha we begin then with that
breaking news out of japan japanese
public broadcaster nhk is reporting that
former prime minister shinzo abe has
died after he was shot during a campaign
event in the city of nara al jazeera's
florence louis reports now on the murder
of the former prime minister
shinzo abe had been campaigning in the
city of nara ahead of upper house
elections this weekend the former prime
minister had been speaking for only a
few minutes when eyewitness reports say
two loud bangs were heard and he
collapsed to the ground
a group of men are seen tackling another
man believed to have been the shooter to
the ground
reports say a 42 42-year-old man has
been arrested
public broadcaster nhk add video of
what's believed to be the weapon
other reports showed abe lying on the
ground his shirt stained with blood
while someone attempted cpr on him
a fire department official said abe was
in cardio and pulmonary arrest he was
airlifted to a hospital
the incident has shocked japan a country
with strict gun ownership laws and low
rates of gun crime
abe came from a high-profile political
family his grandfather had been a prime
minister and his father was a foreign
minister
after studying politics he rose through
the ranks of the liberal democratic
party to hold the position of prime
minister in 2006
becoming the youngest person to do so
since the second world war
he resigned a year later citing health
reasons but returned to par in 2012 when
he set about pursuing ambitious reforms
he pushed an economic agenda dubbed
ubinomics to boost japan's struggling
economy he's been described as a
towering figure in japanese politics
he brought stability to a political
system that tended to kind of churn out
prime ministers uh one after another
not only that but he was also
transformative in japanese politics he
made japan a much more significant
player in terms of regional and i would
say even global security
trying to reshape japan's role on the
world stage one of arbay's top
priorities was amending japan's pacifist
constitution which bars the country from
hostile acts except in self-defense
but the issue was polarizing with polls
suggesting many japanese are opposed to
any change
he still pushed to change the
constitution right up until the end but
his conservatism would lead to new
frictions with his neighbors
a spat with south korea over japan's
wartime legacy resulted in the worst
diplomatic and trade dispute for decades
that contributed to japan's continuing
economic problems
he also stirred controversy with his
neighbors
his 2013 visit to the yasukuni shrine
which honors japan's war dead among them
some convicted war criminals was widely
criticized and he returned several times
but what would turn out to be his last
year in office 2020 brought the
devastation of covet 19. the economy
cratered
abe was widely criticized for
mishandling the crisis
and soon after he achieved the record as
japan's longest serving prime minister
came the surprise announcement that he
was leaving office early citing ill
health second
since i took over the administration
i've worked hard every single day to
revitalize the economy and to conduct
diplomacy that would protect the
national interest
during this time i'm proud to have taken
on various challenges with the japanese
people
but he never left politics remaining a
member of the lower house and retaining
enormous influence within the liberal
democratic party
his tragic and untimely end not only
shocked the nation but is leading some
to ask whether a security lapse
contributed to his demise
al jazeera's rob mcbride has reported
extensively from japan he's currently at
the g20 meeting in bali he's with us now
live uh rob uh it seems then that uh
prime minister shinzo abe has died
following that attack in the city of
narada earlier
that's right as we were preparing to
come on air just a few minutes ago a
number of international news agencies
also kyodo news service in japan nhk the
public broadcaster were all confirming
uh reports from uh political party
political officials in japan from uh
shinzo abe's ldp party is confirming
that the former prime minister had
indeed died but there has been a growing
sense i think of shock
sadness throughout the day as people
have realized the gravity of of his
condition the seriousness of the whole
situation of this appalling attack uh
we've heard that in expressions here at
this g20 meeting of foreign ministers in
bali we have heard it in japan and also
internationally uh throughout the day
the chinese foreign ministry during
their regular daily briefing in beijing
they have spoken about the sadness uh
and their shock at
what has taken place we've heard from
australia's uh prime minister anthony
albanese talking uh saying that his
thoughts are with shinzo abe's family
with the people of japan from boris
johnson of the uk utterly appalled and
saddened from the u.s ambassador to
japan rahm emanuel
is talking about the um abe as an exte
an outstanding leader and an unwavering
ally of the usa and so various foreign
ministers throughout the day have been
speaking led of course by anthony blink
and the u.s secretary of state
who is here as they started to learn
details of this attack it took place
late friday morning in the city of
nara in uh central japan close to the
city of osaka and arbay who had just
started to give a speech according to
officials when the attacker came from
behind he is described as a 41 year old
man a local of the city of nara two
shots we are told were were fired and
abe was hit through the neck and chest
first responders paramedics who were at
the scene described him as being saying
that there were no signs of life he was
described as being in cardiopulmonary
arrest basically his heart had stopped
now there have been hopes throughout the
day that uh attempts would be made and
it could have been successful to try to
revive him indeed the prime minister of
japan fumio kishida who had been
campaigning as are they had on the
campaign trail there are elections
upcoming this weekend for the upper
house he on his return to tokyo talked
about this barbaric and malicious attack
but said that the doctors were still
making attempts to save our base life
we're still
trying to administer blood transfusions
we were told it now seems that all those
attempts were in vain uh rob as i said
japan is a country that that you know
well this will come as a huge shock to
the people of japan violence against
politicians is extremely rare isn't it
it certainly it certainly is especially
in recent uh decades
japan has a very vibrant democracy at
times that democracy the campaigning can
get very heated can get very angry uh
with lots of accusations shouted back
and forth but certainly uh violence
plays a very little role you very rarely
see
violence especially in recent decades
it's equally shocking that the
handgun was involved there is so little
ownership of firearms in japan
we understand that the 41 year old
suspect
is a member former member of the armed
forces armed in japan and also that the
weapon could well have been a homemade
weapon i think what is the most shocking
thing about this whole uh tragedy in
japan and also internationally is that
shinzo abe is probably the best known
face of japanese politics he is the
longest ever serving japanese prime
minister he left office a couple of
years ago but has still been very active
the way the japanese political system
works is that there are various factions
at work in the ldp which has basically
had a continuous unbroken almost
unbroken um
authority in japan since the end of the
second world war and there are various
factions at work while shinzo abe behind
the scenes was still very much in
control of one of those factions was
still a serving member of the lower
house this was upper house elections he
wasn't standing but he was out
campaigning so would still occasionally
go out and campaign using his stature on
the stump making speeches like this and
on this occasion it does seem that uh at
this event he came into
this fateful encounter with his attacker
that does now turn out to be his
assassin
all right uh rob for the moment uh many
thanks indeed that's al jazeera's ron
mcbride who is currently reporting uh
from the g20 meeting uh in bali uh we're
expecting a a press conference
at um
the
hospital in uh nara where the former
prime minister uh was being treated uh i
can just show you the the scene here
we're waiting for it to get underway as
and when it does i will bring you that
live here on al jazeera
well nicknamed the prince shinzo abe
hailed from political royalty his father
was a foreign minister and his
grandfather a prime minister
abe was japan's longest-serving leader
and was the youngest post-war prime
minister when he was first elected in
2006.
abe's name is forever tied to his
economic policies known as urbanomics it
was a way to jump start the japanese
economy he resigned in 2020 citing
health reasons in the midst of the covet
19 pandemic and a series of political
scandals let's bring in michael penn who
is the president of the uh shingetsu
news agency which is an independent news
agency he joins us now live uh from
tokyo good to have you with us uh
michael your thoughts then on the death
of uh the former prime minister shinzo
abe after
these shocking scenes where he was shot
earlier today
yeah well i i don't think it's any
exaggeration to say that this is uh a
history changing kind of uh event for
japan uh you know uh abe is not just
some former prime minister
he is even
was until he just died uh the second
most powerful man in japan uh second
only to prime minister fumio kishida
he was the head of the largest
faction within the ruling party
he was very aggressive and outspoken on
sort of conservative right-wing military
issues and he was pushing the prime
minister very strongly to adopt his
policies uh so this is uh and it was
it's not totally out of uh
out of the range of possibilities that
abe may have returned again as a future
prime minister uh although that was not
likely it was not totally off the table
either so this is huge
why uh
would anyone though have wanted to harm
him was he a divisive figure in japan
well as for the the the the motives of
this individual uh gunmen we we really
don't have enough to say right now but
we can definitely say that abe was a
divisive figure that would be one of the
key adjectives that i would use for him
uh he very much uh represented the the
the conservative and hard right uh
political opinion in japan and so for
those who uh more or less accepted and
and supported those uh policies he was a
hero and the leader for essentially that
movement within the country uh so so for
example the revision of the constitution
the re-militarization of the country
getting involved in in sort of efforts
to contain china that was very much the
obedient position uh whereas those
obviously who did not uh who sort of
supported the traditional past postwar
pacifism or more softer line from japan
uh many of them disliked him or in some
cases even hated him he served two terms
as prime minister the first one uh cut
short after a year due to to health
problems and then as we said he became
japan's longest serving prime minister
what sort of prime minister was he uh
do people feel better off
after his his premiership
um again that's that it's one of those
things where uh it really depends on
which side of the political spectrum you
ask
i would say that
you know he was not able to achieve
many of the things he wanted to achieve
so for example he very much wanted to
revise the constitution during his term
and he could never quite get there
but what he did i mean i think even his
uh
strongest critics would say
that he he provided you know eight years
of a stable leader at the top of japan
he traveled around the world uh you know
for many many years people couldn't even
remember the name of the japanese prime
minister
i'm sorry to interrupt you but that
press conference has begun uh at the
hospital in nara um where uh i think
we've got translation so let's just uh
listen in that was michael penn by the
way to describe the outline of what has
happened
so um
this is dr fukushima i'd like to go
through some of the
situation 12 20 pm
uh the prime minister was carried to the
hospital and
cardio pulmonary arrest was the
situation when he was brought in
we tried to
resuscitate but he was pronounced dead
at 503 pm
there was a trauma to two places in his
body
and it was a trauma to the heart and
also one of the
arteries
and there was a a lot of bleeding
um that has led
to his death
that's it for the explanation from the
hospital if you have any questions
please raise your hand
there is a mic
that we would like you to use
that's right when does he pronounce it
so it's very hard to hear
three 503 pm was the time when he was
pronounced dead
any other questions
there's another person in the corner
there
there's another person raising his hand
in the other end of the room
it's very hard to hear the question
please wait until the mic is with you
was here just to the right of this of
the neck and there was two locations
that there was a trauma by the bullets
very small entry points
other questions
this person here
please use the mic
if you could use the mic please
um
how deep was the wound
the depth is that deep enough to reap
the bullet to reach his heart
person in front please
you've treated him for just over four
hours when he was carried into the
hospital
um how was the situation when he was
when he arrived when he arrived at the
hospital he had cardio pulmonary arrest
it was very difficult
and also we also heard from the
ambulance staff that he was he had
already been in a public cardiac arrest
when they arrived at the scene
and as he was carried to the hospital he
was in a very severe condition
before we undertook treatment
can you
talk to us about the
the trauma and perhaps some of the
intent of the person who shot him if you
could um
guess something from that no we can only
comment on the
trauma and the
injury that
he had experienced
what are the exact treatments that you
uh
executed during the four from however
that we would try
to uh try to stop the bleeding and also
a lot of blood transfusion in the
meantime
another person please
the question is hard to hear
[Music]
broadcaster
there was a lot of blood transfusions
more than 100 units of of blood
the standard 100 units for blood
transfusion
we heard that the family arrived at the
hospital
could you um explain
about um how you how you encountered the
families and what you talked to them yes
well we did meet them and we did talk
about talk to the family about the
situation that the prime minister was in
yes uh the other this other person
please please use the mic
[Music]
newspaper
you talk to the family members you said
but how would the family like
we heard that
his wife arrived what was the exact
situation who came could you just um
briefly describe the situation then
well what i could say was that this
situation of the patient and how that
situation has progressed nothing more
with the bullets still remaining in the
body
during the operation
we weren't able to confirm the bullets
in the body
this is something that it might come
after um some investigation but we we
didn't recognize any bullets within the
body during the treatment
nhk fujita
it was reported two bullets were fired
which bullet was the critical uh
to the injury
this is something that we
i can't be certain all i can say is
there is two entry wounds to the body
the
uh bullet penetrated the skin and uh
went to the
heart and the other one hit the archery
so uh what we can deduct is that that
from the
uh
the blood coming from those injuries has
led to the death
okay
where exactly
was the entry
of the bullet wound yeah around the neck
and there was a large injury around the
[Music]
and the bullet direction was straight
into into the chest
any other questions
[Music]
so
there was trauma in the heart and
through the chest and it hit the artery
and where exactly was it through through
the neck
to the right
in two locations
and then how did that reach the heart
there's a archery archery there
and then that had
that had led to
a lot of bleeding
you talked about operating on him
what did you do in the operation
could you simply explain what you did
we need to look for where the major
bleeding site was
um so first of all we looked for the
side where there was um blood and then
we tried to stop the blood
[Music]
so you were trying to you're trying to
find where the bleeding was yes exactly
right so trying to find the location of
the bleeding and then trying to stop the
bleeding
any other questions please
is due to bleeding is that right what
other factors
yes it's uh due to bleeding the cause of
death was due to bleeding
[Music]
and the bullet reached the heart
did you what trauma did you see around
the heart
yes there was a huge trauma uh to the
heart
what kind
of injury was it to the heart
there was a big hole a big injury to the
heart
because of the bullet entry
well what we can
say
is that the bullet entered the body and
caused trauma and the injury caused
a lot of blood loss and that led to his
death
any other questions
newspaper
so the bullet entered the
heart
but the entry point was the neck
and then you mentioned that you couldn't
find the bullets during the operation
did it penetrate the body did you find
any other
point of injury
on the left shoulder there was a another
injury which we could assume could be
the exit of the bullet
so that's an assumption yes that's not
confirmed but um
that we've assumed and there is no other
uh injury that could just suggest the
exit of the bullet
so yes that's the current situation
as far as we know
[Music]
just to check
when the family arrived at the uh
hospital you mentioned that the time of
death was 503
and then the family arrived at four
o'clock i seem to
read
and uh were they able to be there before
uh the announcement of the death
well uh since arrival at the hospital um
prime minister uh uh was already in a
cardio pulmonary arrest situation
and the family weren't able to
meet with the patient
it's very hard to hear the question
and the entry distance was perhaps the
depth was something like five
centimeters of that particular injury
the question is hard to hear
um
as i've been saying before
and
all i've said as the to the family is
the situation of the patient and that's
that's all i was able to talk to to the
family when they arrived at the hospital
is there are there any other questions
yo miri
were you able to stop the blood
completely
um and was that the reason why um
you know there were
some
degree of control with the
outfall of blood
but because he had lost so much blood
the
blood clotting capability of the body
had been lost
so i don't think we could say that we
could stop most of the blood loss there
was a certain degree that we were able
to stop the blood loss but it wasn't
enough to keep him alive
[Music]
i've heard that the people at the
location performed aed before the
ambulance members arrived and that had
any effect
i only know
since the once the patient was brought
to the hospital so i can't really say
for sure what happened before that
okay another questions
if you were shot in the heart
are there standard procedures to
resuscitate uh i guess there are some
procedures that we can take
[Music]
any other any other one any other
questions
it's very hard to hear the question
no we didn't we did not have the prime
minister in the icu
we had treated him as and when he
arrived at a andy
[Music]
is it right to understand that he died
instantly at the place where he was shot
i think the expression is he went into
cardiopulmonary arrest at the site when
he was shot
so can we say that it was too late for
him to to for you to resuscitate him
there was a huge trauma at the time
so i think the general understanding
would be that um but for us as experts
we would say cardiopulmonary arrest
i can hear
quite clearly
you were not in icu where did you treat
him
at um andy
journalists
freelance
so he was unconscious
and it's probably
not worthwhile asking his expression
but how was his expression was he does
he look was he looked in pain or
we were not able to concentrate on his
expression we were immediately trying to
resuscitate and treat him
so i don't recall his expression
at the location
it's hard to hear the question
so the entry point of the bullet was on
the front of his body
yes fear at the
neck
so there were no entry points that we
can recognize at the back
so two of the bullets entered from the
front and then to the left shoulder
there was an exit wound you said
we couldn't determine the entry further
entry and the tr uh the
track of the bullet
and the exit point that you you
mentioned
to the front of the left
uh shoulder
so you could suggest that it could the
bullet could have entered the neck and
then went to the side i couldn't
conclude that
in any case the entry points were at the
front of his body
any other questions
it's hard to hear the questions
so if the entry point is around the neck
and exit to the left shoulder how
did it go through the heart
it could have been the first bullet it
could have been the second bullet but
this is inconclusive
i couldn't say for sure
so there was a huge injury to the wall
of the heart yes that's right
it's one of the uh ventricles one of the
walls of the heart there was a big
injury
any other
what would happen to his body
what is the process after this
no i don't think the details of the
process afterwards has not been decided
yet
any other questions
[Music]
to tend to um prime minister
i don't have the exact figures because
people were coming in and now there was
a large team um i would say basically
over 20 people were there
thank you
any other questions
bunching
who were the family members who came to
the hospital is it just his wife yes his
wife was there but i don't know about
the rest of the family members i'm not
sure
nhk
you said that there was an injury to the
um heart wall
so
entry from the right and then went
through the
the archery can you go through some
details of the of the injury on what you
suspect the bullet the track of the
bullet is
i think the broad bullet as it enters
the body it's not going into the
straight line so i can't say
conclusively the track of the bullet
within the body
so the entry point was one of the two
entry points around the neck
and eventually it went into the heart
and it might have gone out through the
shoulder
that's what we think at the moment
um but this is not conclusive as of yet
are there any other questions
it's hard to hit the question
[Music]
for the hospital side of course um it
was a tragic accident and uh tragic
incident and from the hospital side we
tried to
do as the best we can to resuscitate him
but i would just like to offer my
condolences
this is just for the check
so there were no
injuries to the back of the neck and the
there were two entry points in the front
and then what looks like an exit wound
on the left shoulder yes that's right
okay another question
[Music]
when you had to deal with the ex-prime
minister did it have to stop the
standard procedures within the hospital
to attend him what do you mean stop
within the hospital you mean
but of course um we had gone through
standard procedure but as and when we
knew that we needed to have more members
um we took uh we collaborated with the
the hospital the other department the
hospital to to increase numbers
ex-prime minister had chronic illness
do you think there is any uh relation to
the to death of
the injuries that he had incurred this
time around no i i i can say that
there's not there's no relation between
the two
are there any more questions
[Music]
and when you say neck injuries they went
over at the top of the collar bone
yeah the height was just above the
collarbone yes
there's no particular trauma on the
collarbone itself
any other questions
is that all for questions
then i would like to conclude the press
conference for today
okay
we've been listening to one of the
doctors uh who was treating
japan's former prime minister uh there
at the hospital in nara after
he was taken to the hospital having been
shot
the doctor that briefing the press
on uh
the prime minister's condition when he
arrived in the time of death apparently
he said over 20 medics worked on the
prime minister for a matter of hours he
was taken to the hospital shortly after
midday local time was pronounced dead at
5 03 p.m local time that's 0803
gmt the former prime minister had
sustained two deep wounds to the right
side of his neck and his chest he
arrived in a state of cardiopulmonary
arrest
but had suffered serious blood loss uh
he received something like 100 units of
uh blood
we couldn't save him uh the doctor said
he was just bleeding too profusely
uh al jazeera's rob mcbride who's
covered japan extensively and reported
from there
throughout his career is currently at
the g20 meeting in bali but is with us
now and was listening into that press
conference rob what do you make of what
you heard
yeah i mean they were going into uh
extensive details about attempts uh to
uh save shinzo abe's life to try to
revive him attempts that were ultimately
in vain
this was the medical team at naira
medical university this is the hospital
to which shinzo abe was taken he was
first taken by ambulance from the at the
location in nara this is a city in
central japan where he had been
appearing on stage giving a speech as
part of political campaigning ahead of
important upper house elections this
weekend
in japan that's where this medical team
these are the doctors who apparently led
that medical team talked about his
injuries when he first arrived
paramedics at the scene just after the
uh attack had happened talked about uh
the
former prime minister being in a state
of cardiopulmonary arrest effectively
his heart wasn't working at the time now
there were reports so we knew from the
very start of this uh awful attack that
he was in a very grave condition uh but
uh the medical uh uh medical uh teams
there and officials in japan were
informing us that attempts were being
made it seems uh to to save his life but
the doctors confirming that when
shinzo abe was brought into the hospital
at 12 20 that was within an hour of him
this attack happening late morning
friday uh on the this location in nara
that he was uh already there were no
vital signs they said effectively they
still he was still his heart was still
stopped
effectively he still hadn't been revived
whatever attempts were made by the
paramedics on the way to the hospital
and then they just have described in
really very lengthy details about the
extent of his injuries about the two
entry wounds it does appear as though
there were two bullets had entered
shinzo abby's body we know from uh
reports at the scene that two rounds
were fired from this homemade handgun
that was recovered from the scene that
it seems as though one of the bullets
had uh punctured the heart of the former
prime minister
either the same bullet or the second
bullet it seems had ruptured an artery
so there was extensive bleeding and as
you mentioned there they talked about
using 100 units of blood and would seem
to be an extensive operation we heard
that blood transfusions were being
administered uh it seems as though those
attempts were being made throughout the
afternoon until it seemed uh some time
after shinzo abe's family had actually
arrived at the hospital by 5 pm local
time they then finally declared that
shinzo abe was dead
rob what was the former prime minister
doing there in nara in uh in the west of
the country today
yeah this was uh a political campaign
we've gotten uh uh upper house elections
are happening this weekend uh in japan
and so all of the politicians were out
campaigning shinzo abe is a very
influential figure still in the
ruling liberal democratic party is
basically the conservative party of
japan which has pretty much been in
continuous uh rule since the second
world war apart from one or two breaks
in continuity so it is a very
influential shinzo abe is the longest
serving prime minister in japan he
resigned from office a couple of years
ago but it was still uh because the way
that the political system works in
control of one of the factions that's
very influential within the ldp so he
was still pulling the strings behind the
scenes if you like a very influential
figure in japanese politics and also a
member of the lower house so he was
still an active politician and so at
times he would be out using his
political stature as he was on this
occasion at this rally to go out and uh
make a speech in support of one of the
candidates for the upper house
is something he would be uh he would
have done less so he would have made
less public appearance appearances uh
since he was prime minister and it does
appear that on this fateful occasion he
appears on stage and where he meets his
attacker who ultimately would become his
assassin
violence rob in japan against
politicians extremely rare what will
people there be making of it
i think people are terribly shocked uh
by this act of violence in recent
decades especially
there has been very little violence in
japanese politics it has a very uh
vibrant political culture it has a very
mature democracy
certainly politicians at times will get
angry they will shout at each other but
violence is very rare also handguns are
extremely rare because of the very
strict
firearms laws that exist in japan there
are very few firearms around that will
shock people i think what's left people
the most shocked is the fact that shinzo
abe is probably the best known uh face
of japanese politics domestically and
internationally as we said he is the
longest serving prime minister and
someone who comes from a long political
dynasty uh in in japan
al jazeera's rob mcbride reporting live
from the g20 meeting in bali rob for the
moment uh many thanks indeed uh craig
mark is a professor
at uh kiritsu women's university he's
the author of uh the abe restoration and
he joins us now live from uh tokyo
professor good to have you with us uh
how will shinzo abe be remembered
well
as was just mentioned uh the longest
serving uh prime minister in japanese
history
he was able to make a remarkable
political comeback in 2012
after serving only a year from 20
2006-2007
he
dominated the opposition parties which
uh were divided uh he won two elections
two general elections 2014 2017
and even after he departed
the leadership in 2020
after claiming illness which is which
returned and also coming under some
criticism for uh
some political scandals and mishandling
the covert 19 pandemic he uh still
was a very important force in japanese
politics he headed up the um
largest faction in the ruling liberal
democratic party the ldp
and of course he uh was a uh
such a
dominating presence internationally
as uh
being part of the g7 he hosted the g7
summit and the g20 summits
[Music]
japan
and so he'll be considered one of the
most important figures in
japanese and world politics
okay so internationally respected but
domestically was he a good prime
minister and he's famous for ubinomics
but but did urbanomics actually work for
for the people of japan
well that is his more controversial
legacy um abenomics really didn't
succeed in its objectives of trying to
break japan out of decades of economic
stagnation
real wages for ordinary people
has remained flat
the corporate side of japan the big
companies they saw their share
prices rise they
amassed massive profits which they
failed to reinvest into higher wages
so economically speaking uh japan
continued in its economic doldrums uh
ubinomics had record deficit spending
record quantitative easing the loose uh
fiscal policy
uh one thing shinzo abe was able to do
though was to resurrect the
trans-pacific partnership uh treaty
multi-national trade treaty which uh
looked in real trouble when
the united states withdrew from the
treaty uh particularly when donald trump
was president uh but he was able to
continue that going with support from uh
countries like australia
professor he stepped down twice uh due
to ill health the first time after just
a a year uh but then he went on to to to
become you know the longest serving uh
prime minister in japanese history uh he
didn't get everything that he wanted
to do done though did he i mean he he
failed to change the constitutional or
amend the constitution
yes that's correct uh one of his
long-held ambitions and of the ldp in
general was to
alter
the article 9 of the japanese
constitution the u.s design constitution
has never been changed he wanted
to hold a referendum to have the
self-defense forces
installed in the article 9 of the
constitution
and he had a chance to do that when uh
both
the
up both houses of the diet had a super
majority but he lost that in the 2019
upper house elections however in a sense
that didn't really matter too much
because uh in 2015 his government passed
uh security laws which allowed uh again
to
the self-defense forces to engage in
collective self-defense with allied
countries like the united states but
also potentially with australia the uk
india
france and germany so in a way
that's his probably his major legacy in
terms of altering japanese foreign and
security policy he really uh began a
revamping of japanese
potential military strength
which has continued on the the present
government of uh his former foreign
minister prime minister kishida yeah we
talk about how internationally respected
he was tributes are being paid by world
leaders uh
as uh we speak including uh south
korea's president who said the shooting
of japan's
uh japan's former prime minister abe is
an unforgivable actor of of crime um in
his in his own backyard i mean leaders
in the region didn't always see eye to
eye with him did they
no they didn't um and south korea in
particular was
the most difficult of japan's near
neighbours
north korea of course kept on testing
missiles
over and near japan so they were
permanently hostile but
shinzo abe tried to get a settlement
with the previous
government of uh pakian hay
to settle the so-called comfort women
issue that is of sex slavery during
wartime japan
but when
the
government of
president uh moon uh took over
that deal apart and so
south korea was uh probably the most
challenging relationship and uh china
was uh
also had its challenges although shinzo
abe did eventually meet with xi jinping
at a number of summits and was able to
maintain maintain fairly stable
relations with
japan's largest trading partner
and his biggest policy failure in
foreign policy was probably with russia
shinzo abe held numerous summits with
vladimir putin and he hoped to resolve
the territorial disputes of the northern
territories which occupied by the soviet
union after the second world war
and uh but that ultimately failed okay
so he did have a
record in foreign policy professor it's
been really good to talk to you many
thanks indeed for being with us craig
mark there in tokyo